the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we've talked on the phone
this show and i think on the regular
show before just about sort of like work
rules and attendance policies and
vacation time and related issues and
there's a couple stories that have come
out sort of connected to hurricane Irma
in terms of employees who were possibly
or definitely going to miss work because
you know there's a hurricane and in some
places an evacuation order and
reportedly the manager of a pizza hut
that was in the path of hurricane Emma
was threatening to discipline workers
who followed the evacuation order and
left outside of a designated time frame
I guess the idea was they weren't
telling the employees not to evacuate at
all but they were saying we want you to
do it only within a particular time
frame and if you do it outside of that
it's going to be a problem and a photo
began circulating of a picture of
someone took a picture of a memo at a
Jacksonville Pizza Hut location which
had a list of instructions for employees
and it says you know basically it's
telling minimum wage employees that they
need to put their jobs above their
safety
well it's saying that safety is of our
utmost importance when I got to our
employees but you still have a
responsibility to the community and you
have to show up to work and then if you
don't show up to work it's going to be
treated as a no call no show presumably
even if you tell us ahead of time
right that's pretty ridiculous 24 hours
before the storm and they had to be back
within 72 hours of the it doesn't really
say what like is it they have to be back
within 72 hours of the beginning of the
storm or of the end of the storm it's
not really clear and you know they okay
fine this is Pizza Hut and who knows how
connected to this Pizza Hut corporate is
this might have been a decision made at
the store level it's not totally clear
to me
for me the bigger issue is just that the
general way in which employees are
treated when it comes to this stuff
around safety and just basically common
sense and it relates to work culture in
the US at large
yeah there's no common sense here I mean
I understand some jobs you can't take it
off for any reason even if there is a
storm coming if you're a first responder
if you work in the medical field I mean
people need you and that's the time that
you're gonna be most called upon right
but if you work at Pizza Hut I mean
you're not delivering an essential
service for know well I don't know I
mean you know if people do need food yes
they don't need prepared food they don't
need someone to go to liver pizza to
them I mean not you'd like to hope that
people stocked up on canned goods and
stuff like that well even if they didn't
it wouldn't be the minimum wage Pizza
Hut employees so responsibility to
resolve that for people and I think
we're also forgetting that from a
totally pragmatic standpoint if
everything's flooded customers can't get
to Pizza Hut and Pizza Hut delivery
drivers can't get to customers either so
like what are you what exactly are you
gonna be doing there was a stir a story
out of hurricane Harvey where manager of
a I don't know VA's Pizza Hut or some
other restaurant and delivered pizza
using a kayak oh is that right it I baby
the people were hungry and she fulfilled
her job but you can't expect that from
everyone I didn't hear that one no
that's quite a dedicated employee and
yeah I mean what else can we say I think
what I can say is I am NOT going to
Pizza Hut again well I think it's
well-known and infamous at this point
that I worked once worked at Domino's
Pizza when I was 17 years old and they
told us that for no reason could we take
off Super Bowl Sunday you know it can't
take that day off I think that maybe
it's the pizza what would you call it
Pizza Christmas it's like the Super Bowl
of the pizza industry right yeah ok but
I mean I think that one makes sense yeah
right it's sort of like if you say I'm
gonna work retail or I'm gonna sell cars
but I can't work weekends it's like what
weekends are when many more cars are
sold because that's when more people
have time off to go and look at cars so
I'm gonna do retail but I can't work
Black Friday you gotta work like right
now to work back Black Friday when I
worked at Circuit City I was there at 6
a.m. on Black Friday which seems late
now compared to stores that open at 6
p.m. the previous day or something like
that I once waited in line on Black
Friday and once I got to the front of
the line all I got was a Butterfinger
that's horrible yeah what was it like
there all night was it a deal on no
there was no deal I just thought it'd be
funny if I waited outside all night and
then I ran a store and bought
her finger and letter I want bunny is
not the word I thought but that's hey
kids have a lot of time on their hands
yes you know Brian Kilmeade from Fox
News compared victims of 911 basically
to slave-owning generals who were trying
to destroy the way of life of the United
States by fighting a civil war to keep
slavery legal this is the weirdest thing
Brian Kilmeade on Fox and Friends was
speaking with interior secretary Ryan
Zinke before he joined Vice President
Mike Pence at the 9/11 memorial in
Pennsylvania of course there's a 9/11
memorial in Pennsylvania in addition to
the one in New York City the
Pennsylvania one dedicated to those who
died when hijackers took over flight 93
on 9/11 of 2001 and Kilmeade said do you
worry that a hundred years from now
someone is going to take that memorial
down like they're trying to remake our
memorials today and then he continued to
talk about Confederate figures who have
monuments to them like robert e lee as
if there's any similarity whatsoever
between the victims of the 9/11 attacks
and those fighting to perpetrate slavery
during the Civil War I don't know if the
reaction should be that this is an
incredibly poor taste and a disservice
and disrespectful to the victims of 9/11
or if it's just indicative of a level of
stupidity the likes of which should not
be on national media in the United
States it's just because the analogy
doesn't make any sense it's completely
backwards I mean if there was some
statue of Osama bin Laden out somewhere
in the middle of the country yeah then
that would make sense to draw the
comparisons who Confederate generals I
guess because they may even yack the
country it's closer yeah closer it's a
closer analogy than the victims of 9/11
and generals of the Confederate Army and
it was a total non sequitur I mean it
really nobody knew why he even chose to
make this analogy you didn't think it
through and you know maybe some people
out there just think that we shouldn't
have statues at all or commemorate
history in any sort of way yeah I don't
I don't see that I mean I think it's
important for us to educate ourselves
about the horrors of the past and you
know even in a positive light to see a
statue of like Abraham Lincoln or George
Washington I mean right
it doesn't really upset me no it doesn't
upset the idea of statues is not really
at issue here and that's why it's so
weird that Brian Kilmeade would even
choose to bring this up and Zinke seem
to realize this was not a good direction
for the conversation to go because he
gave a really vague answer just saying
monuments are part of our country's
history yeah and everyone is going to
fall morally shorts who has since
everyone is a sinner
I guess all statues you could point to
and say that person had moments of
falling short morally other than Jesus
of course yeah but the responses coming
back to me and he said that because
we're not erecting a statue of Jesus
then we're all going to face him on
Judgment Day and he's going to look down
upon that but yeah we can't be having a
statue of Jesus on government property
that was unconstitutional there's that
but also now that I'm thinking about it
by saying that any statue other than a
statue of Jesus would fall short of
perfect morality yeah he kind of is
saying that the victims of 9/11 and
Confederate generals both have misdeeds
somewhere in their lives and thus no
statue is perfect actually now that I'm
thinking about it zinc II also is part
of the problem here because that's he's
also making an analogy saying hey
whether it's a victim of 9/11 or a
Confederate General fighting in favor of
slavery they both have things in their
past that we might find distasteful and
it also depends on what denomination of
Christianity you follow too because
there are plenty that are opposed to
idols in general that we shouldn't be
erecting statues of Jesus that we
shouldn't have icons and any sort of
imagery of him yes I think the Westboro
Baptist Church follows this - they don't
believe there should be any images the
best of my knowledge
ya-huh injury because they look at it as
like an idol idolatry yeah yeah yeah I
mean I know you know in Judaism that's a
common thing like absolutely no statues
or representations of you know God or
wood whatever you call it even the
prophets like Moses well I don't know is
Moses considered a I don't know no I
don't think Moses is a prophet okay
I don't know yeah I mean I know I should
probably know more about this I did go
to Hebrew school
three months once in fifth grade but I
guess we didn't cover that that day you
can spend a lot of time in the modern
working world sitting down and you can
also spend a lot of time sitting without
having a break from that and it turns
out that it's really bad for you it
seems that there is significant health
benefits to standing up you know some
people say once an hour
other other studies say like for example
one recently published that you should
be standing up at least for a couple
minutes every 30 minutes and it seems
like no matter what the particulars are
in addition to exercise and hitting a
health having a healthy diet etc that
you could be doing all that stuff and if
you sit for long periods of time it's
not good for you I think of airline
pilots who often even during long
flights you don't see them leave the
cockpit at any point I mean I think it's
very common like on when I go to Vegas
usually I fly JetBlue because they have
a nonstop flight from Boston to Vegas
and there's no first class on a lot of
JetBlue flights and if you so you can
often end up sitting like right by the
cockpit and it's going completely
unobstructed view 6-hour flight yeah
the pilots will not leave the cockpit
and I often think about pilots and not
standing but obviously office work and
many many other jobs come to mind as
well it's really not good for you this
makes me want to do the rest of the
bonus show standing up because I'm just
worried about my health and safety we
stand a lot here actually yeah you have
the video editing desk is a is a high
desk where you could sit in a high chair
but we also can you can stand at it and
I have you ever suggest as well and
right stand most of the day actually
other than I'm doing the show I'm
basically standing most of the time I'm
here you do stand while you do work a
lot more than I do I tend to divide my
time maybe 40% of the time standing 60%
of the time sitting I'm a tough time
writing when I'm standing is that right
you find that I don't I don't find that
now I just got the option I have an
easier time writing while standing
because my chair that I have at my desk
has arm rests so actually when I'm
sitting my elbows hit the arm rests and
it's more difficult to write so I prefer
to stand while I'm typing on my computer
yeah I mean I think this whole thing
makes sense because it's not like humans
were designed or evolved to sit in
chairs not really you know like just to
stand up and lie down if you're going to
sit maybe it would be on the floor or up
against the rock or something you should
seems like it's so incredibly unnatural
yeah you know not good for your posture
if you're you're sitting incorrectly
what I might do is start bringing my
lack laptop and lay down under the
studio desk actually and do work yeah
and I think that the being in repose is
a much more natural position but that
yoga ball trend where people would bring
yoga balls into an office so it's yeah
straight north they're back the whole
time
you can still slouch in a yoga sitting
on a yoga ball it's true that's the
thing I never fully understood it seemed
kind of like a gimmick I don't know I
get that you have to engage more of your
muscles if you have no backrest and I
guess if you're on the yoga ball you
also could be sliding sideways so
there's probably something to it have
you seen those treadmill desks yes I
have those seems absolutely ridiculous I
mean I'm sure they accomplish the goal
but but when I read about how people
have set up basically a reading platform
on a treadmill and when they're doing
just reading that they put the treadmill
at like 1.5 miles an hour or something
like that like a very very slow walk so
it doesn't become in any way distracting
and that if you read for a half-hour
that you end up getting a lot of walking
in every single week just while you're
reading it's actually pretty interesting
to me and it's a lot safer than reading
a book walking around outside because
who knows what you'll run into I mean me
if I'm going to go in that direction I'd
rather just listen to an audiobook and
take a walk outside but hey that's just
me well that is just you I think that's
the best conclusion we can draw from
that
okay well listen I don't think it's any
surprise that sitting is bad sedentary
lifestyle is bad and I've been aware of
this since we moved into this studio
nearly two years ago I have had a
standing desk
yeah and we're actually talking to the
manufacturer of the standing desk I use
about sponsorship on the program because
I believe it's a great product but I
don't mention the company now no I mean
I just I think it's pretty dangerous if
you go to work sit eight hours a day and
then you drive home maybe hours hour
commute and then you go home and watch
TV you're sitting down for the entire
day you could have two people both of
whom go to the gym for 45 minutes five
times right one of whom stands at work
and takes the subway in another who sits
at work and drives in and even though
they might have an identical diet and
the identical time spent at the gym by
the time of the gym here athletically by
visually drastically different I'll tell
ya alright I think I'm done
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]